翻訳: Tomoko Hori
校正: Maki Sugimoto
これはどこにでもある
道端の雑草です
私が数日前に撮影したもの
ですけれども
これはどこにでもありますから
これを見て何かを
感じることはないと思います
アスファルトの割れ目に
しっかりと根を張って
育っています
この炎天下でも
この元気さですから
この逞しさはピカイチ
と言えます
雑草は 踏まれても踏まれても
また立ち上がるパワーを持っています
そして 放っておけば
また （根が) はびこって
手がつけられなくなる事もあります
この逞しい雑草がこのサイズ
だったらどうでしょう?
これは「エリアンサス」という巨大植物です
皆さんがもしこのエリアンサスの
そばでこれを見上げた時
きっと自分が小人になったような
気持ちになると思います
この５メートルを越す巨大植物も
先程の道端にあった
雑草と同じ「草」なのです
皆さんは この巨大植物を目の前にして
何を思うでしょうか
私は10年程前に
このエリアンサスと出会って
まずは異常なまでの
巨大さに圧倒されました
そして これはきっと
何かの役に立つはずだと思い
研究を続けてきました
皆さんは 今日ここで
エリアンサスと出会って
何を感じるでしょうか
これを何かの役に立たせたいと
感じるのではないでしょうか
さて このエリアンサスは
当初は家畜が食べる飼料として
ここ熊本の農業試験場に導入され
熊本で育ってきました
つまりエリアンサスは
「メイドイン熊本」です
エリアンサスは
同じ株から何回も成長して
なんと30年以上も
長く生きていられる
長寿の草です
これは初夏の様子ですけれども
夏には 地中 深くから
養分を吸い上げ
これを地上に噴き出すように
勢いよく成長します
秋には穂が出てグッと大きくなり
５メートルを越える
巨大植物になります
冬には寒さにあたって
地上部は枯れてしまいますが
仁王立ちになって 立ったままです
野外で立ったまま乾燥するのです
これをそのまま収穫すれば
乾燥した保存性のいい燃料になります
そして この同じ株から
翌年にはまた緑が吹き出し
秋には穂が出て
冬には乾燥して また収穫する
これを何回も何回も
繰り返すことが出来ます
枯れた草はよく燃えますよね？
だから まずは燃料に
してみようと思いました
バイオマスの木質ぺレットの
代わりにしたら
よく燃えて安価にできる
いい燃料が出来ました
エリアンサスを栽培すると
そこには草の森が出来ます
夏には葉っぱが生い茂って
太陽の光が地面まで
届かなくなるので
エリアンサスの下には
雑草がなくなります
害虫だって減って
病気が減ります
地中深くから養分を吸い上げて
それを表面の土に戻していくので
土地も肥えていきます
これは エリアンサスを栽培して
収穫した後の様子ですけれども
エリアンサスを栽培した時に
ほとんど草が出てこないことが
わかると思います
このようにエリアンサスを
栽培すれば栽培するほど
雑草がなくなり 病気が減り
そして土地が肥えてくるのです
そこでエリアンサスを栽培して
豊かになった土地に
麦を栽培しました
エリアンサスと同じ畑で
しかも同時に麦を栽培できます
麦の周りをエリアンサスが
取り囲んで成長しています
これはまるで作物を
エリアンサスが育みながら
育っている感じです
これと同じようにソバも
作ることが出来ました
エリアンサスから
エネルギーができるのなら
まず福島でこれを
栽培してみようと思いました
福島ではマンパワーが
なくなって農地が荒廃し
農地を維持することが
出来なくなっています
これに対してエリアンサスを栽培すれば
農地の荒廃を阻止し
森林化を止め
そして同時にエネルギーを生産する
そういった新しい試みが
いま始まっています
エリアンサスをいっぱい栽培すれば
あとは雑草のように勢いよく
成長していきますから
手がかかりません
必要なのは収穫するだけです
農業を維持するには
非常にいい方法になります
ここ熊本では 震災の影響で
農業を辞めてしまう人が
増えていると聞きました
耕作放棄地にエリアンサスを
栽培すれば
農地を守ることが出来ます
雇用を生み出すことが出来ます
そして 新しい農業
新しい産業を
生み出すことが出来ます
エリアンサスは
今までになかった
新しいものを生み出す
パワーがあります
復興を支援するパワーがあります
これはエリアンサスを
栽培している風景ですが
エリアンサスを栽培すると
畑にエネルギーがみなぎってきます
必要な作業は収穫だけです
そして これすべて
エネルギー 燃料です
二酸化炭素をどんどん吸って
エネルギーにします
その最も強力な光合成の
システムでもあります
私はこのエリアンサスに
底知れぬパワーを
感じずにはいられません
そして同時に このエリアンサスには
周りを取り込み
育む優しさがあります
エリアンサスの雑草パワーは
農業 それからエネルギーの
世界を変えると信じています
そして その雑草パワーは
熊本の復興に役立つと
確信しております
どうもありがとうございました
(拍手)